Hãy chào mấy đôi giờ tuyên bố khẳng đình, tổng thống Mi đơn ông Trump sẵn gặp nhà lãnh đạo chử tiên Kim Chương Ngân,
mà không cần điều kẹn tiên quyết, nhìn mạnh chính xác của Washington đối với bình nhóm không thể đổi.
Theo quan chức Mỹ, bao nhiêu thương tình măng tính lịch sử chức đây giói bên trong nhìn kỳ đầu tiên của tổng thống Trump,
tương gó phản ổn định tình hình trên bản đạo chử tiên và tạo lìm tạng cho đối thoại.
Từ một đàn đối đưa ra sâu ký chử tiên bài tòn sẵn sản đối lại đối thoại với Mỹ,
nếu Washington từng bảo ở chính xác mà mình nhóm có là thủ định,
đồng thời yêu cầu tôn trong vị thị hiện tại của nước này.
Nhà lãnh đạo Kim Chương Ngân Trân rằng, trên vận cảnh thiên quan hệ phục thuộc và thay đổ của Mỹ trong thời gian tự giang tự
chục khi đề ngọt phản đối thoại với Washington,
bình nhóm vẫn suy chỉ lập trường tướng giám vẻ hành quốc,
và cạnh báo sẽ đáp trả mạnh mẽ nếu có caynh đổ bị cói là khư khách.
Dời qua sinh nhìn định tiền nhiều ngoại sao mới có thể mở ra cơ hội nối lại đàn phản Mỹ châu,
chứ quốc cạnh của những đồn đoán, về cuộc gặp có khả nắng sảy ra trong phuyền thâm của tổng thống trong tự chung của bảo tháng mai họ tháng tư tới,
sau những khá bia về vấn đề em nhé và nguyên của vận là thay thức lần.